30-minute workouts 20-minute recipes
10-minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout is a 15-minute
standing app exercise at home so we will
be working on
the entire mid section while standing up
so this workout is low impact it's knee
friendly and it's suitable for
anybody and everybody so let's get
started and let's get your abs
on fire
[Music]
[Music]
we will complete a total of two rounds
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with a short 15 seconds rest in between
so let's get straight into the workout
stance shoulder width apart with your
knees pointed forward
arms just by your side let's just start
with easy
cross crunches alright so the goal here
is to drive your knees up towards your
elbow
remember throughout this workout it's
all about engaging your core
it's not about rushing through the
movements okay
so knees up crunch and really
try to drive your knee towards
the opposite elbow and remember keep
your back flat and stand tall so do not
punch forward this is wrong okay
stand tall cross and cross
so you should start to feel the work on
your core especially your obliques
all right good so just check it out the
next workout
is going to be a curtsy side crunch so
again
find your base what i want to do is
place both arms up
cross over as you come up crunch to
the side step back up crunch step back
up and crunch okay so again
driving your knee to your elbow
so remember it's a side crunch spread
your legs out
cross and tap
if this is too tough you can reset tap
and cross okay tap reset
and cross so choose your option
and up good job and up
cross and let's keep going
cross up good
find that balance working on your core
stabilizer
as well up good job okay
shake it out reset now let's work on the
other side okay
so again anchor your left leg right into
the ground
step your right leg back up cross to the
side
up and crunch so driving your knee
to meet your elbow okay
nice and controlled movement crunch step
back
and crunch good job
find one focal point okay look at one
focal point
look straight ahead and crunch
good job if you want to you can drop the
opposite arm
and just place it on your waist
good crunch release
crunch up and back
10 more seconds starting to feel your
abs
on fire working on
your balance as well good job okay
right the next workout we're going to
work on some
rotation okay and we're going to add a
step back
so what i want to do is step your left
leg back rotate to the right
reset back and rotate with a combination
good so step back rotate bend your knees
slightly
it's not a full lunge it's just a slight
step back
and rotate again with every
exercise i want you to make sure that
you're standing
tall stand tall and proud do not
hunch forward i don't want to be seeing
this okay
stand tall stand proud arms close to
your body
and rotate your torso
good keep rotating
left and right step back
push it back
and keep a soft bend on your knees
good job shake it up all right this next
workout
is actually my favorite it's also from a
cake boxing move
so it's a forward knee tuck okay
so what i'm going to do is start in a
neutral position
drive your knee forward step back
and forward okay so the standing foot
you should be standing
on your tiptoe up and step back
up back up okay
so it's about driving your knee forward
feel the crunch on your abs
stabilize up good job raise your hands
up
imagine that you're using your knees
to hit someone right at their core
okay so it's forward it's not up it's
forward good job forward
alternating between legs
keep going forward tiptoe
push breathe out and
good job all right next windmill okay
this is a slow movement
yet it really targets the deep core
muscle
so step with your right leg facing out
right hand pointed down what i want to
do is reach up
keep both legs straight reach up slowly
using your core to drive your body back
up okay simple movement
but still working on your core so
look at the arm
that is facing towards the ceiling all
right
now let's change side left leg out right
hand up
and up slow movement
nice and controlled if you have a
dumbbell what you can do
is grab onto the dumbbell for that extra
challenge okay
up back down up
and slowly shake it up all right
let's end with a short core blaster
jab and cross you might be wondering how
is this working on my core well in
kickboxing moves
it really works on the entire core so
left leg forward right leg back
jump and cross as you throw the punches
i want you to
rotate your torso and use the power
from your hips and your core okay
so really punch forward jab and cross
punch forward
using the momentum and the power
from your torso twist twist pivot on
your toes
keep pivoting left and right keeping
your arms
strong look forward
keep going keeping
your arms close to your face guarding
your face throw
and pivot nice
very very well done okay we're going to
repeat the entire round
once more okay starting with a simple
cross
crunch so stand shoulder width apart
with your toes pointed forward
arms up ready cross remember
stand tall drive your knee towards
your elbow okay rotate
and twist good job
keep breathing crunch it up
crunch good job feel the work
on your obliques now let's bring the
pace up slightly
there you go stay light on your feet
keep crunching you got this
come on let's go last ten more seconds
give me five more one two
three four last one
five well done okay
curtsy to a side crunch again all right
again look straight ahead all right
left leg back step back as you come up
find your balance crunch it up up
and crunch okay if you need to reset
tap back up and crunch
good job tap and crunch so remember to
keep your standing
foot the knees of your standing front
foot
slightly bent up back
and crunch and again to find your
balance
look at one vocal point okay
call workout it's also about working
on improving your balance crunch
a few more breathe out
one more and
reset good now let's work on the other
side okay
you will always find that one side it's
always harder than
another side i struggle on my left side
okay good
let's go arms up back
crunch it tap step back crunch
and crunch
suck the belly in stabilize
slow controlled movement
don't rush through the workout do not
just let
your leg collapse nice and controlled
up still working on your abs working in
a core
it's not just about doing crunches but
you can also work on your core
by doing standing ab exercises okay
keep going crunch that's five more
two more one more
and good all right
step back with a torso rotation okay
so keep a slight bend in your knees
keep your feet slight let's go step back
rotate step back and rotate
so tighten the core tighten your mid
section
rotate and look the opposite side
good chest up
and twist
and i want you to really pull your body
back
right into the center okay make every
movement
a conscious action so rotate
pull it back drive it back into the
center
good keep going
[Music]
go as far as you can left to right
and well done all right
the next workout is a forward knee
driver okay my favorite kickboxing move
it requires lots of stability and also
lots of call work
so remember to tiptoe on the standing
foot
up drive it forward step back
forward tiptoe forward okay
hit it like you mean it let's go
knee that person right in front of you
right at the core
ah good job bring the speed up
let's go knees forward
remember to tiptoe as much as you can
suck your belly in and forward okay
drop your arms good job
you are looking strong
keep going we're also breaking a sweat
let's go
break very well done standing
win meal okay so let's start by
facing your right foot out okay right
arm down
left arm up and now let's go try to
reach
try to keep your legs straight reach
again
drag it up pull it up reach
looking straight up reach good job
if you want to add the extra challenge
you can grab hold
off a dumbbell or a kettlebell okay
that will add the extra intensity
on your core alright now change side
left leg to the side right hand up ready
up good job breathe out
in keep both legs straight okay
feel a slight stretch on your hamstrings
[Music]
up and up
okay guys do you know what this is your
final
core blaster and also the end of your
workout
so let's do this together let's end this
workout strong with a jab
and punch okay remember to pivot on your
toes
bend your knees keep pivoting and give
me a strong
punch and cross right
into the camera okay look straight at me
strong jab and cross keep going
remember that your shoulders should be
in line
with your punches twist
rotate your torso twist lots of energy
come on keep going twist
nice
[Music]
few more strong punches keep going do
not stop right now
i'm loving those punches keep them
coming
and bam well done
very very well done that is the end of
your workout okay
now just take a moment to bring your
heart rate down
breathe in breathe out
and now let's just do a little bit of
stretch okay
let's just inhale tiptoe stretch your
core out
and exhale inhale
you've done really well breathe in
and exhale few more
breathe in extend
and exhale and now feel
trunk rotation just to loosen out
the muscles all right
few shoulder rolls
and now give yourself a big clap
okay very very well done you have
completed
a 15-minute standing ab workout so
do combine this workout video with my
other cardio workout as well as strength
training
on my youtube channel let me know how
you got on
in the comments below okay if you
enjoyed this video give this video a
thumbs up
be sure to share this video with your
friends and family members and also do
get them to join you
in your next workout session if you
haven't yet subscribe to my youtube
channel
then go ahead and click the subscribe
button and i will see you
in my next video all the best